thanks to Germany's largest trade union
IG Matta there's a new minimum wage year
of eight euros fifty per hour for temp
workers and Innova snow has to pass it
on to her clients she had the temporary
employment agency in garrison kitchen
her clients are mainly from the
metalworking and logistic sectors there
are companies that say it's too
expensive and really can't pay that wage
you have to keep that in mind but in the
sectors in which we were mainly in
larger companies it works they also have
to pay their permanent staff higher
wages after collective bargaining
agreements
Marvin Eklund is benefiting from the
latest minimum wage he had to break off
his job training and down works as a
temp like a lot of his colleagues he
goes into the temp office on Friday to
take care of paperwork and maybe get an
advance on his wages then he's done for
the week as of January 1st he'll get 8
euros 50 an hour as opposed to the
current 819 the more money the better
that's really all there is to say when
asked if that's enough or if it's still
too little he said it's fine I can live
pretty well off it I can pay my rent
electricity phone TV food clothing
everything so I'm satisfied as far as
that goes on Sofia
Malvina klonoa is one of 170 people on
our Boston employees the 61 year old
thinks the minimum wage in our sector is
fine she especially hopes that the
agreement will help improve the poor
image of temporary work she wants her
own company to be a role model with temp
work especially at the lower wage level
people are assured a certain level of
security they get paid on time they get
transport money or a ride to work they
can get an advance every week so it's
become a very popular model for working
and most of my employees want to keep it
that way
the metalworking and engineering union
IG Metall was involved in negotiating
the minimum wage for temp workers but
for stephan Schaumburg the agreement is
just the beginning since many trade
unions aren't strong enough to negotiate
a minimum wage he wants a legally
binding national one in many sectors IG
metallus of the fortunate position of
being able to set wage standards they
don't need the support of the state to
push things through so it's about having
solidarity with trade union stuff don't
have the power to negotiate their own
minimum wages that was also the case
with temp workers until recently they
got two seasons at the temp agency in
Gaza and Kishen they take a different
view as a business owner
Anna basta has no use for a legally
fixed minimum wage that obligates all
employers in Germany it's been of course
I'm opposed to a unified national
minimum wage we have wage autonomy in
Germany which has proven itself over the
years every employer should be able to
reach agreements with its bargaining
partners and the government should keep
out of it
they about it often she's worried that
jobs will be lost if a national minimum
wage is implemented but the minimum wage
for temp workers isn't a problem for her
she hasn't lost any of her clients due
to the wage increase at least not so far